hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the 2020 chasuble Masters it's
Magnus Carlsen versus onigiri and we are
in match two so Magnus won the first
match and now Geary needs to retaliate
to force and match three and this is the
first game of the rapids so let's dive
straight into it Magnus with the white
pieces and they go into into a very very
long Fioretti call struggle with
something awesome happening at the end
so let's check it out the d4 by Magnus
we have Knight f6 c4 e6 sorry about that
knife to have three ended d5 so the
Queens gambit declined is on the board
we have Knight c3 and c5 by giri we have
capture son d5 captures on d5 by the
night and II for now pushing the knight
back character son c3b captures and now
Geary wants to get his King to safety so
he just straights everything off so
characters captures Bishop check so you
can castle with with tempo well we have
Bishop to d2 captures captures and now
just the castle so Gary's Castle to
safety and Magnus still needs to develop
the light-square bishop to do so so he
does Bishop to c4 and now Knight to d7
we have castles by Magnus and now b6 so
this is all very very standard theory of
this line and both of them know it very
well of course we have rook a to d1 at
some point you or you do want to play d5
create a passed pawn and you do want
support to push that pawn bishop the b7
putting pressure on the e4 pawn and now
look after a one defending with rook the
c8 putting pressure on the bishop here
and now Bishop to b3 and rook to e8 so
both players have fully mobilized their
forces and now the most common idea here
is h3 but Magnus actually goes for rook
to e3 it's not a new idea but it has
been played only only a handful of times
so here Knights the f6 by Gary adds
another attacker to the e4 pawn and here
no more known moves our Queen to e1
defending d4 pawn this way and the Queen
to d3 defending d4 pawn again this way
however
magnus chooses a third idea which was
never played before and goes d5 and
as a move 17 that we have a completely
new game so what's happening here what's
the point of d5 well Geary says I'm
interested in that as well and he
captures on d5 however Magnus doesn't
recapture but rather pushes c5 so a
temporary pawn sacrifice or maybe not
even a temporary one challenging the
night we have Knight to e4 and now a
most interesting move Queen to e1 saying
okay now there's the threat of rogue
characters night you will not be able to
recapture because of the pin here so
gear removes the Queen now with a double
attack on the e5 pawn but for the moment
the knight defendant but that's why
Carson's next move is is a beauty Knight
to d4 he's saying okay I wanna bring my
knight to b5 indented b6 to create some
sort of a nice forth but also you're
welcome to capture the pawn on e5 but
capturing the pawn on e5 is well it is
just awesome if you go for rook captures
on e5 you get f3 and now you cannot move
the knight because well there would just
be a double attack on the rook so you
have to go rook to h5 create some
threats here against the H do pawn but
now h4 and still the knight is under
attack you move the knight and now G for
you go after the rook rook has to move
and now Knight f5 is just deadly because
you will win the rook if the well of
course if you capture then rook e8 will
result in checkmate but if you move the
rook
Daniel 1897 check and you win this rook
so it's not a problem
so quite a deadly idea to unleash in a
rapid game but it's it's fair to assume
that it's something Magnus prepared at
home and now only only Unleashed it so
Giri goes a6 he says I'm not touching
that pawn I'm just gonna take away the
b5 square from your knight and now
Magnus goes h4 he wants to play h5 h6
and well start an attack against the
black King or just you know in in the
style of Leela I just get the pawn all
the way to h6 so Roxy to d8 by giri and
now comes f3 kicking the night away
Knight to c5 now attacking the bishop
and are just h5 continuing the
to the path at the path to h6 we have
nice the East six by Geary offering a
trade now but here Magnus just goes
Knight to f5 and his pieces are getting
closer and closer to the to the black
King we have d4 by Geary now attacking
the rook and now look to d3 and now the
rook shifted from from the e-file to the
D file and the rook to e3 move now does
make does make more sense and it's a
fair affair to notice that this Bishop
is much stronger than this Bishop
because of the ponies on f3 now so
Geary's next move is is to be expected
he although you could play Bishop d5 and
try and trade your bad Bishop for
Carson's good Bishop but he instead
wants the traded like this and okay here
Magnus accepts his pawn back we have
rook captures on d4 rook captures we
have capture son d4 end captures and b3
but now before recapturing first magnus
goes for a nice solution soup queen to
g3 now threatening checkmate
and only after g6 defending this we have
a character son b3 recapturing the piece
and here it's again a lot of pieces in
front of Geary skin capturing a knee
point is very interesting but it's not
good because if Queen capture well if
Queen captures then it's fairly simple
just wrote characters in this will
result in checkmate
since the g7 square is covered by the
knight however it's also very
interesting what happens if the rook
captures now it's the same idea you just
sacrifice the Queen and you deliver mate
rook checks Queen blocks and this is
again made because the night again
guards the g7 square so here after a
character Sun b3 we have looked the D
egg by giri now offers a rook trade this
way but this does not help him all that
much feel free to pause the video here
and win the game for Magnus while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting the D weld
the the absolute best move is just
unleashes all health and for us if you
just want to enjoy the show it's East 6
and there is nothing for black to play
here it's just just a hopeless position
because now
everything is being threatened your
queen is hanging you cannot get the
Queen away from the rook because the
rook is hanging this is hanging this is
hanging like everything is just
happening all at once and there's no
good move if you trade Queens then just
real characters is mate in one if
instead you try something like Queen to
be you cannot go to see it because night
chairs just picks up the Queen so if you
try something like Queen to be eight
still Queen g5 now with a double attack
here but you're not really interested in
that you can also just go something like
this deliver checkmate so we'd probably
see something like real characters on
before but now captures and it's it's a
forced checkmate like characters check
here and maybe win the g8 the g7
checkmate so after East sick east sex
it's just unbearable again retried Queen
to see one check so he got the Queen
away from the White Queen
but after King h2 he only then captured
the rogue but now it's just east of now
threatening upon t8 Queen all rook to
deliver checkmate
so Gary defends it not like that but
with a queen queen to c8 but now again a
move where everything starts happening
all at once Queen e5 attacking this
attacking this threatening this it's
just just insane so here a Gary
delivered one check rook to h4 check he
wants to get the night away from there
so maybe to avoid checkmate but Magnus
just played King to g3 and it was in
this position I'll move 34 that uh
nigiri resigned the game and the game 1
of the second match goes to Magnus
Carlsen who is one step closer to
winning the chess table Masters 2020 and
here you resign because again too much
is happening all at once everything is
still hanging
this is hanging I mean there's no way to
stop this you could prevent checkmate by
capturing the knight so now ok there's
no checkmate
but still you just force force black
Queen to capture it the King has nowhere
to go
and after this check you can just pick
up the rook and I mean it's a queen
against Bishop fairly straightforward
but yeah yeah Gary just spent way too
much time in this game Magnus completely
outplayed him in the opening and he knew
exactly what he was doing Gary was you
know caught caught off-guard definitely
in this game
and I think here we had like less than
five seconds on the clock when the game
ended and Magnus said like almost eight
minutes so really really surprised him
in Game one and Geary now has the has
the bonds back and then you know win
this match in order to force match three
which we are all looking forward to as
you know three matches is always better
than two so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
heroes diamond of Emil the daiquiri our
Thomas Connors Michael Considine and
Robert pipes for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here think of for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the chest
blue Masters 2020 checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and if you
haven't do check out who was strong the
link will be in the description below
see you soon